I was going to framing to put in my
house maybe he would
um it looks good it's really good could
you tell them more detail like your
favorite part about it I'm trying not to
describe that's a little too much detail
and if you get a close look but if you
look at her for too long can I explain
so Ethel's more poodle so she's a little
fluffier and then Elvis is more Maltese
and he's got straighter hair yeah
linguine yeah and then what's this
what's happening
they did it like that yeah okay so Grant
definitely practiced because this isn't
a first go like I know I know enough
about him now that like he likes things
to be perfect that's true but I didn't
practice I haven't drawn anything
there's like a stippling he's shaded
yeah so I used to be very good at
drawing but I haven't drawn in like 15.
you're a charge you're an artist 20
years okay